I was I was playing a few nights ago and
a guy just catapulted himself across a
chasm shotgun me and it dabbed on my
corks and I was like like for a
microsecond I was mad about it and then
just seeing him be like oh I was like
yeah this is versus the game swatch show
that pits your favorite games consoles
franchises and hot-button issues against
each other this week it's the Battle of
the battle Royales as we square off
player announced battleground against
its fierce rival fortnight battery out
there's a lot of battles in that
sentence arguing the case before night
is me I've spent the last couple of
weeks making game spots history about
our games so I hope I know a thing or
two about the genre and five a pub G is
Oscar Deus who is more likely to sit
down for a nice roast chicken dinner
round his mum's house than get anything
resembling a first place in pub G each
are going to argue the corner for their
game over the course of three randomly
picked topics with the overall winner
being decided by you though wonderful
viewer last week's fight between spyro
and crash saw Oscar notch up yet another
win with 62% of the vote for his case
for Spyro so are though I'm knocking
down a peg or 10 this week to vote in
this episode we're going to be throwing
up a clickable poll right here on
YouTube or if you're watching this over
on Gamescom let us know who you think is
won the debate in the comment section
below
right let's get into it
[Music]
alright alright baby song we've done
together in it is the first one we've
done together the first time you would
have lost as well by the industry I was
about to say I've seen how time treats
you and then I was gonna be nicer oh but
now I'm just gonna clap yeah yeah yeah
bring it on go pick a first one then
let's go
the first topic though is gameplay but
that's obviously a very broad topic but
I would personally say I prefer the flow
of a pub G match to the flow of a
fortnight match and that's partly
because of the the slower nature of pub
G the slower movement the more hardcore
feel of it means that the tension is
always higher particularly towards the
end if you if you are particularly good
at it like I am I check it as you go you
probably I mean I had chicken Kiev last
night okay when you do win or when you
do even just get a kill it feels so good
it feels like more rewarding somehow
because of the more hardcore nature of
it and that also comes from the facts
that I think pub G has more
customization options when it comes to
sort of attachments and stuff and the
the depth in terms of its weapons is far
greater whereas fortnight's depth at
least in my eyes comes from the building
side of it actually what I think that
does is just unnecessarily complicate
things
whereas pub G is a simpler concept that
is done to a deeper and better level
than fortnight ci I love them both for
completely different reasons but I think
for now has added a whole nother level
with the building mechanics and that
means the meta is constantly changing
like if you look at the day one release
of pub G today with the first match
played and pub G played out very
similarly to match of property that I
played yesterday
whereas day one fortnight it was a lot
of people getting to grips with the
building mechanics trying new things now
people are like you you shoot a squad of
tajmahal appears out of nowhere to give
these guys cover you talk about the
weapons I agreed there's there is depth
in a weapon customization in pub G but
in fortnight you can have certain
weapons that from used to demolish
people's structures you can have sniper
rifles if you're trying to just pick off
people and play stealthy there's just as
much depth to the gameplay I believe
that comes from both the combination
and of weapons and the building stuff
they play in tandem and when it comes to
tension for a good pub Jean match I need
to set aside like half an hour at least
in fortnight I can jump in go somewhere
busy have some excitement in the early
game kills and then the tension will
build towards the end when all these
blue city structures come up yeah I
agree you do have to sort of invest a
little bit more and Pub gee I think not
in terms of money but in terms of time
and but I think that's the that's the
beauty of pub key because that is where
the tension comes from the fact that a
death means so much more imposing
because you've put so much more into it
than a fortnight you go in you rock
about you jump about you maybe get a
couple of kills and then you die and you
just do it again there's no real sort of
like a loop there for me pop G despite
it's sort of more hardcore sort of
appearance I think it's actually easier
to get into for a newcomer I think it's
easier to grasp the concept of it at
first so I think it's a higher barrier
to entry because a fortnight you can go
in and you instantly understand the
shooting and then slowly you'll learn
what weapons to pick up what rarity
ratings mean how to build or as pub Jean
that's its DNA was from like the armor
games which are like super tactical as
much as I do love pub G it is asking you
is asking like a preschooler to become a
reading sometimes Jonah B Marine is your
preschool I really dislike you sometimes
Dave and I would like to go homes but
unfortunately I'm contractually obliged
to continue the rest of this debate
all right the style and I think four
nights gonna win this because it has
some I mean I think I'll win this
because I have some I mean prog G has
earth style it's got the military
simulator milsim sort of vibe but that
has been tried again and again and again
where's 4/9 there's not really any games
that look like fortnight it's embraced
its cartoony aesthetic that it got from
the single-player campaign and that's
given it so many opportunities to be
larger than life and bombastic like the
other gameplay elements that are in for
tonight wouldn't work if it was
more realistic looking game that freedom
and style has played into the gameplay I
thinks it means that they've been able
to do the whole meteor thing and no
one's been like oh that wouldn't be real
it's allowed them to do things like the
fan off stuff it makes it more
accessible it allows a wider audience to
approach that game and find something
that they love in it it brings so many
light-hearted moments I was I was
playing a few nights ago and a guy just
catapulted himself across a chasm
shotgun me and dabbed on my corpse and I
was like like for a microsecond I was
mad about it and then just seeing him
being like oh that's like yeah so you
know I mean on that note specifically
you can actually make yourself tab and
put in pub G when you're diving at the
plane if you look all the way to the
left your character does that and I
think guys I think it's funnier in pub G
because it's inside a place but in
general I agree with you I think that
the style does in both games does feed
into the game plan it's in the same it's
the same in pop G as what is important I
accept obviously the opposite where in
pub key it's obviously like you said a
more realistic style and that feeds into
the more realistic gameplay and it would
look weird if a character with military
uniform on was going around flossing and
dabbing on your corpse and stuff you
know I mean it would be amazing but I
think it also styled isn't just the
aesthetic is also in terms of the
layouts of the maps as well and I think
that it's very obvious in my mind at
least that pub G's maps are a lot more
open I think than fortnight's in pub G
is like I feel so exposed because of the
landscape that I find myself in a pub G
just tweaks every area of it of its DNA
like that in order to fit this hardcore
sim angle that is going for and I think
it does that really well although I
think for might has done well with it
style and it does feed him well with its
gameplay at the end of the day it is
just a bit of the B Tech Pixar isn't it
P tech picture I mean it's it's a little
bit it's it's it's like a Disney film
but not what is good again I love pop G
but it doesn't use personality and when
you're so invested in a
you want to inject a little of your own
personalities because you've fought so
hard for now I disagree I disagree
because you know else doesn't have
personality big war war is a hardcore
environment if you haven't fought a war
well I haven't and from what I know from
film z-tech argument yeah yeah they're
no ongoing support and content for night
I mean like last the last big week
before we had the Thanos thing it's like
the biggest game in the world doing
something with the biggest movie in the
world what I think does really nicely is
that they might only have one map but
they make tiny iterations here and there
to keep it interesting the crater that
hit til two towers meteor sorry that's
like being repaired it's like you go
into the game this week and you see like
trucks so it's like cement holes into
the ground stuff like really nice tweaks
like that as well as having like the big
things like dusty divot appearing now
you have to fight in a crater weapons
that are added quite frequently we just
had the epic and legendary burst rifle
now all that stuff's doing a really good
job at keeping it fresh before the
battle pass really took off to inject
any personality into into your
experience meant buying stuff but now a
free-to-play game that is giving you
weekly challenges and content earn and
skins too and and fun of notes to use
I'm completely fine with that it gives
me a little extra objective to work
towards I agree I do actually really
like this stuff the epics doing
particularly with the map in fortnight I
think that's really cool the way it's
changing a little seeds being sown all
the time however that isn't really a
match with the fact that pop G Corp
literally adding new maps all the time
in pub key there was obviously Miramar
and then there's San Hawk and there's
another map coming as well so in the
Adriatic Sea so it's like this by the by
the time water bows right you're gonna
have four times as many maps that's four
nights and obviously for tonight's map
is changing but to me there's no
comparison and on top of that they're
obviously refining the maps as well in
themselves at the same time as making
new ones you still have new weapons and
new items being added
improvements I think it's really Stark
to look at pub G now compared to pub G
even six months ago you mentioned like
the change that you've seen that change
has come around because they're
terrified afore that they've they've
started to put more effort into
injecting new content because of a
fortnight I don't there's a bad thing
like I'd like the pub G got competition
I was really worried that it was
stagnate I really like that new a chance
new Chandra approached and made them
support their game more and more and
even beyond that for a night has cross
play and a bit a big reason of me
playing fortnight was because I wanted
about our out experience with my friends
and not all of them wanted them in the
military same experience and all of them
had a PC so I was able to just play with
my friends who were playing on xbox on
PC in it it worked seamlessly and it's
it hasn't really been a game or a
company that has done cross play like
they have and as effectively as they
have and it's there's no reason why it's
now the biggest game in the world
I think the variety they keep adding the
support they keep adding the environment
that they give to players has meant that
people from all walks of life have
started playing it I think you're right
in the they're definitely healthy
competition for each other and I think
you're also probably right in the the
reason pubsey core for our improving pub
key so rapidly now is probably a
response to fortnight but the fact that
we have two such good games occupying a
similar space but very opposite ends of
the spectrum is let's face it great for
everyone and and I play both and
continue to enjoy both but yeah it's
that competition that keeps things fresh
and that's why I'm glad you're here
David because you keep me from
stagnating in real life there's a very
pleasant end to that argument wasn't it
it's the first time versus yeah but I'm
still gonna knock you out though shut up
you prick let us know who you think
debated their case better by voting in
our poll in the top right corner of the
video or if you're over on games.com by
putting your thoughts in the comment
section below
it'll be your votes that decide who wins
so make yourself heard right time for
everyone's favorite section to show the
week's quickfire round a series of dumb
fun questions written by
the rest the UK team and pinky promise I
haven't seen any of these ahead of time
how would you explain your game to
someone 40 years older than you I mean
how'd you explain fortnight it's like
putting up a garden fence but someone's
trying to shoot you at the same time and
the one the last one live were the
biggest garden fence wins if your game
was an air freshener what smell would it
be I think I think fortnight would be
one of those ones that you plug in and
it gives you a new scent every day
because it's always changing that's
great actually yeah thank you I do that
how do I give you that well night would
be one of those ones that you plug in
and it gives you an incentive yes right
yeah you've won that one
if fortnight was an acronym like pub G
or would it stand for off righteous now
I'm - I can't top that
try reenact your favourite emote from
the game mine's called the boneless I do
it sitting down but it's like you all
your limbs go leave if you could bring
any famous slash fictitional character
into your game who would it be and why
Jeff Goldblum because I just love Jeff :
I'm a Robocop we call Judge Dredd we've
had John wick as well but it's do it nil
I don't know you I don't think you were
playing for that please put a picture
picture a little up there
I hate this we write mm-hm
remember to get your voice heard in our
poll or in the comment section below and
tell us who you think I get their case
better and if you enjoy this episode of
vs. make sure to hit that subscribe
button
we'll have new episodes of the show
every Wednesday thanks for watching and
I'll see you next time also go and watch
my history of battery out it's really
good if it's out yet it might not be out
yet
it's really good though
you